here's a function and exist these
characteristics in this domain so draw
it for that domain at least draw a
possible thing that it might apply okay
so you've got lots of options right take
a seat like this is very very broad okay
so we just need to make sure it sits all
the boxes for these and then you can
draw whatever you like if it's there
okay all right so let's start from the
stuff at the top so f is grand zero okay
now just visually what does that mean
that's right so if it's positive right
it's that's what I was looking for it's
above the oh okay so that means take it
yeah sure yeah we get there okay so
that's where it is that's where it is
now how is it behaving this is the first
derivative right so it's less than zero
meaning what kind of function is it it's
decreasing right so it's gonna go from
high to low okay one last quality about
it second derivative is greater than 0
so this describes not gradient but open
cavity and it's concave up
alright so decreasing it's kind of going
down
it's concave up that means it's it's
facing like Vince Franco came up okay so
that's right
so I also need out of position so let's
draw actually set of axes now it begins
at a and it ends and B I don't think
they tell us anything about a OB right
so I'm just gonna put them both in the
yet so he's gay he's me okay I've got to
make sure I stay above the axis and I've
got a gunner from a higher point to a
lower point yeah so that's taken care of
the positive buff taking care of
decreasing because it's going down now
the concave up pot you just have to make
sure it has that kind of clever tutorial
that's it
so what if we changed some things what
if supported let's get rid of this what
a suppose I changed it this let's make
that okay
so what's that going to mean yeah what's
it going to look like how will it be
different it's still gonna be okay but
look like a cup right but it's going out
okay let's up let's change it again
suppose I said suppose I said that the
second derivative is equal to zero does
that mean
okay sir but that cannot be possible
yes I can because it's well I so the
first thing I want to catch which is
helpful is you think are normally we
think of this as point to infection like
possible points of infection right
that's a good thing to think but the
reason why it's not actually what we
have for you is because this property is
true over an interval not just at a
single spot okay
so therefore what you have to have is a
straight line okay it doesn't have quick
a be it's not it's not concave up it's
not gonna catch more up or was not going
to flow down it right it's just it's
just flat and if you think about you
know what kind of function might this be
this is kind of like your MX plus B kind
of situation right so it's just the
linear function well your different key
it once you get em because the constant
drops off and then when you
differentiate a second time the Adira
there's the there's the concavity means
you okay so really just make sure you go
through them one by one take a hold of
your companies may be fun yeah oh you
mean you mean for this
okay well I can if we send this what
might that mean in some ways I could
live otherwise I could leave it as is
right now that would be fun okay if you
have a good cavity of zero right that
means your credit isn't changing right
this tells you how this is changing in
this country and this is change so what
have you've got it's still going to be
leaning at the company change okay
on the other hand I said this okay so
now this is concave down
this means it's increasing or or what or
stationary okay so now if I'm increasing
your stationary and I'm concave down I
could have this kind of situation that
implies yeah it could be stationary
there that's about it but it doesn't
change all that much I mean I could have
done the previous one not have a
stationary point there
just just curved is no station point
there the first three moves never
actually equal to zero there but it's
still obeys the properties we've been
given